congratulations on the film that
absolutely loved it well thank you and
it's kind of like as intense as and
experiences it can be it feels like
something like you can kind of bring all
generations of a family to to experience
in the cinema was that something you
were coming striving towards yeah I mean
I want as many people to say it doesn't
matter what age they are yeah and I
don't only that but I want them to see
it in a cinema
you know III there's very little
opportunity to make these kinds of films
these days you know it's designed for
the cinemas made on a big scale but it's
not a superhero movie or a franchise or
an animated film so that puts it in a
tiny percentage of the movies that play
you know in multiplex is that so that
that's that was important for me I also
felt like I wasn't making a movie that
as a history lesson you don't need to
know anything about the First World War
and in a way I wanted to make these two
men could be almost any nationality it's
about the human experience of war and it
operates like an unconventional war
maybe it's not a you know it's not
moving about combat there's not a lot of
bloodshed in it it operates almost like
a ticking clock thriller as much as
anything else and you know or an even at
times a horror movie so it's it's a it's
placed by its own rules was there
uninterrupted shot an element that was
there quite early on or was it something
that kind of as you were developing the
story okay this kind of needs to be told
in this way yeah it was it was baked
into the the very fabric of the script
you know it was my idea was two hours of
real time and you know no cuts
nothing between the audience and the
characters and that feeling that you're
sort of locked into this distinct lock
and you're also experiencing distance
and a difficulty with the men and
there's no way out that was part of why
I made
in this way and I know it's inspired by
stories from your grandfather and does
light has the experience I kind of
researching and developing the film
allowed you to kind of understand a bit
more of kind of what you went through it
was any like yeah Isis that you found
only the overall surprise when you
actually recreate and we're recreating
probably a thousandth of the war and
still huge but it's a you know absolute
tiny percentage how how impossibly
difficult it is yeah to even walk and
move in the mud and you fall over the
whole time everybody falls over it's
like walking on ice the shear you know
the conditions you know even for us you
know there are three weeks it's
unimaginable that people would live
there for three years and so yeah you do
have a newfound respect for the people
you know I already had a respect for
them but it's it's even larger than it
was when you you just have a sense of
what they'd actually lived through yeah
and the first one was like there's so
many kind of big Second World War
pictures and the First World War feels
slightly more less explored as a result
is that more freeing as a filmmaker or
was the almost certain pressure to
deliver a bit more well I feel like
there's a reason on the whole that it
hasn't been so explored as a second
world war which is that the nature of
the war is quite static and so that the
big challenge for us was to find a way
of telling a story that traveled if
someone was delivering a message that he
had a journey to take a landscaped
across you know that was constantly
changing and evolving and so that way
you begin to understand the scale of the
war in a different way to into to
perhaps other World War 1 movies but yes
I mean that that was the key was finding
this moment in 1917 when the Germans
sort of disappeared and retreated to the
Hindenburg Line and suddenly the British
were cut adrift and this land that
they've been fighting over but never
seen and and that means that the movie
you know goes through not just the
expected environments of World War one
trenches and
but also through farm houses and
orchards and woods and burning towns and
and and day and night and through you
know some some beautiful nature as well
as the hell of what the men have created
and more so yeah it feels to me like we
found another another story to add to
the many brilliant stories of World War
one a different different flavor